[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bienvenue dans
questions aux sénateurs je suis très
content de vous retrouver pour cette
deuxième saison question sénateurs c'est
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
d'acropolis et de public sénat où on
reçoit un sénateur ou une sénatrice
aujourd'hui on reçoit samia ghali pour
jour bonjour ça va bien installé très
bien parfait eva bienvenu on va
apprendre à vous connaître on va
discuter bien le bonjour à vous si vous
nous regarder en direct actuellement sur
twitch sur la chaîne acropolis bonjour à
vous si vous nous écoutez en podcast et
bonjour à vous aussi si vous nous
regardez en replay sur public sénat le
canal 13 de la tnt
je m'appelle le jean et cette semaine
donc j'ai le plaisir de vous accueillir
samia ghali merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
ben c'est un plaisir merci à vous de
m'avoir invité côté je vous en prie tout
le plaisir est pour nous encore une fois
on va parler de vous de votre parcours
votre actualité on va apprendre à vous
connaître et puis on va on va aussi
discuter avec vous pour essayer de voir
c'est quoi une sénatrice cki samia ghali
comment ça comment ça marche qu'est ce
que vous faites et voilà c'est un peu la
rencontre de deux mondes 1,6 et des
sénateurs qui vient de rencontrer des
jeunes sur internet et des jeunes sur
internet qui pour certains d'entre eux
c'est la première fois de leur vie
qu'ils vont pouvoir poser des questions
directement un sénateur une sénatrice
donc
donc voilà je suis sûr que ça va bien se
passer vous êtes aussi vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste élu dans les
bouches du rhône
on peut dire que vous êtes l'élu des
quartiers nord de marseille on peut le
dire comme ça non je n'aime pas ce terme
je suis socialiste des bouches-du-rhône
et parlementaires je suis une élue des
quartiers dans en tant que
j'ai été maire et je suis maire
honoraire des 15e et 16e arrondissements
mais je trouve que ce que c'est un peu
réductrice et un peu réducteur dit pas
d'autre on ne vit pas de pour d'autres
sénateurs ne dit que pour samia ghali
c'est vrai vous avez raison je savais
que si je suis la seule sénatrice a qui
ont mérité leur demeure ses actionnaires
de marseille la maintenance et sénatrice
socialiste des bouches du rhône ont même
si je suis né dans les quartiers nord
c'est une histoire avec mes quartiers
nord j'assume et je suis fier mais pour
autant je reste sénatrice des bouches du
rhône bas très bien samia ghali
sénatrice des bouches du rhône qui va
donc répondre à nos questions moi je
voulais commencer par l'actualité chaude
de ces derniers jours après on va pas on
va parler de vous le breakbeat
vous y comprenez quelque chose vous
comment je comprends plus rien je vous
le dis comme ça tu veux pas non mais
c'était vraiment ça me suis endormi hier
soir j'ai cru comprendre quelque chose
je me suis réveillé ce matin je
comprenais plus rien parce qu
apparemment ça a changé ça a changé non
mais je crois que vraiment là c'est
manger tes pas pour leur excite mais
maintenant je me dis sinon vous qui
partent quoi ma fille c'est bon en une
fois deux fois trois fois quatre fois
non un coup je veux après on attend vos
report vous reportez mais franchement
ils ont eu maintenant du temps pour
s'organiser pour dire qu'il voulait
partir pour faire une chose et là je
comprends pas donc
quand vous voyez vos collègues
parlementaires de l'autre côté de la
manche la les britanniques script cache
pas je les vois par un nom mais fall en
ce moment je dirais westminster ces gens
chez eux
c'est chaud ils sont ils ont du mal à se
comprendre à s'entendre donc j'avoue
mais pour l'instant ils bloquent quand
même la machine quoi donc moi j'aimerais
bien que maintenant ils décident de
partir et que ça que ça se passe parce
que bon c'est tout c'est leur choix ils
l'auront voté ou alors ils vont font kg
il faudrait qu'il refasse un référendum
et qui permettent aux britanniques de se
repositionner parce que peut être
certains n'avaient pas compris au moment
du vote mais ça arrive souvent les gens
vous savez sur le moment de la colère et
oui dans son ensemble va on se casse et
puis au final avec le temps quand on
commence expliqué que quand tu en
arrives dans le concret de se dire oh là
là mais attends mais moi je serais je
suis pas d'accord ça je veux pas c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça que maintenant
il ya un franc succès en france aussi
c'est déjà arrivé ça qu'on voit un truc
avec finalement on hésite selon vous
savez des fois en france on fait des
choix des choix politiques et ou qu'on
vote certaines sont en tout cas les
français sont pour aux thèmes tel
positionnement et puis avec du rock
l'insee ils vont peut-être qu'on n'a pas
bien fait quoi conduisant alors il y en
a plein -c'est-à-dire s'est blessé au
quotidien c'est à dire que
on vous demande de paepe de baisser les
impôts quand bc impôts vous demande de
mettre plus de fonctionnaires notamment
quand vous avez aujourd'hui ni dans le
monde hospitalier
le manque de fonctionnaires dans le
monde hospitalier l'éducation nationale
la police chez les pompiers donc tout ça
fait qu'après moment il ça se paye avec
des impôts donc c'est bien de diminuer
les impôts mais malheureusement derrière
ben bon bah on va en parler en toute fin
de service public
au sénat on s'entend mieux qu'à la
chambre des communes au royaume uni ah
oui non sénat on est d'abord on est
respectueux
les uns avec vers les autres eux
il ya une collégialité de travail on
peut s'engueuler sur des textes
ce matin c'était chaud mon nom ma
commission mais pour autant toujours
dans le respect respect de l'autre et
chacun a le droit d'avoir ses idées de
les défendre en des fois c'est fait avec
plus de on va revenir on va revenir
dessus
est ce qu'il ya des marseillais dans le
chat qui nous regardent si c'est le cas
fait le geste - sienne ben ouais ce
serait chouette
vous avez voté vous avez grandi à
marseille et vous n'avez jamais quitté
cette ville c'est que je suis né à
marseille
vous êtes vous êtes né à marseille moi
j'ai une vraie marseillais c'est pire
choucha donc moi je suis né à marseille
j'ai grandi à marseille et j'adore mais
j'aime ma ville c'est vraiment chez vous
marseille ah oui c'est vraiment chez moi
marseille
j'ai lu aussi vous ayez fait un cap2
comptabilité c'est est bonne ce truc-là
content quand tu as vite et pas du tout
pas du tout juste ça s'est passé comment
le racontez nous d'abord il faut savoir
que je disais ce matin d'ailleurs en
commission celle et je vais manger était
dans une école de soeurs ça paraît pas
comme ça
oui je sors de bonne soeur ah bon ouais
jeter nos écoles de filles que des
filles une bonne soeur voilée on en
reparlera il nous engueuler quand on met
tait quand on était trop décolleté ou en
mini jupe qui disait maintenant vous
repartez c'est pas possible qu'ils
surveillaient les unités devant la porte
comme sa droite soeur monique d'ailleurs
ils étaient trois dans la porte et qui
regarde et comment nous étions vêtu vous
avez fait une partie de votre scolarité
dans cet univers-là à une grosse partie
de ma scolarité et alors vous en garde
un très bon souvenir parce que d'abord
j'ai fait
j'ai fait le catéchisme voilà comme quoi
j'ai dit comme j'ai dis finalement ça
m'a pas vraiment changé quoi je sais pas
ça ne va pas changer
non par contre sa main ça m'a appris
plein de choses et surtout ça m'a ouvert
ça m'a ouvert sur les autres mais ça
sera aussi important et donc ensuite
votre orientation ça c'était comment
comment est-ce que vous retrouvez en
seat et comptabilité non c'est ce qu'en
fait tout simplement parce que le débat
c'est comme ça quand vous avez les
conseillers d'orientation considère que
sont londres dont vous venez qui vous
êtes hots ont bifurqué vers des filières
professionnelles
ouais donc je ne se retrouve en sap et
bep compta je les fais je suis réussit
d'ailleurs les deux sans aucune
difficulté d'ailleurs mais c'était pas
du tout ce que je voulais faire
alors vous voulez faire quoi avant je
voulais qu'il dit civil donc et au décor
avait cette ville pour ceux qui nous
écoutent ça veut dire quoi alléger des
services et aides en fait c'est
ingénieurs dans les routes et dans les
rangs avoir c'était j'étais attirée vers
plus vers la
vers tout ce qu'ils étaient
architecture urbanisme travaux d'accord
mais donc du coup c'est la paix et sa
stabilité
ça n'a absolument rien à voir mais du
coup vous avez fait quoi après c'était
quoi le début de votre recette après
j'ai fait après j'ai fait un bac pro et
vie de marin bac pro en fait en en
communication voilà c'était une première
année où il y avait le bac pro en fait
qui était inquiété un mis en place ça
n'existait pas à l'époque c'étaient les
premières années et au final après j'ai
trouvé une
quand j'ai fait mon stage j'ai trouvé je
travaille dans une mutuelle qui m'ont
regardé et j'ai continué et donc j'ai
arrêté d'accord vous avez arrêté j'ai
arrêté parce que non non j'ai arrêté
j'ai arrêté l'école pour pour travailler
d'accord d'accord pas d'accord moi je
l'avais en venir évidemment la police
j'ai fait quand même je suis allé en
parce que je suis sorti du bus était pas
évident sortir du bp je suis allé à
diderot donc dans un indice est
justement une filière classique pour
aller faire du génie civil
mais après bon c'était d'abord ça a été
compliqué parce que quand vous sortez du
site du cursus normal
on dit que vous iront rentrée en plus
été très mat que devant ça a été
compliqué et en plus financièrement
c'était très dur pour mes parents parce
que j'étais passé à côté de la maison et
c'était très compliqué donc voilà donc
je suis revenu faire un bac pro compta
en communication et de là je suis j'ai
trouvé un boulot ils sont assez dans mon
boulot les dark bichon qui dit des
travaux publics au service public en
tant qu'élu c'est cohérent
d'accord mais c'est vrai servi par
exemple comment est-ce que vous en est
venu à la politique ce que jusqu'à
présent voilà c'est le parcours de la
marseillaise bon mais dans mon école des
soeurs dans l'autre et qualité sur ça
commençait déjà souvent grâce à l'école
des soeurs comment ça non parce qu'il y
avait une prof de français en fait qui
était ma prof de français et je pense
certainement puisque j'étais pas
vraiment trop à ma place
j'ai peut-être et quand c'est ma prof de
français d'histoire d'ailleurs on
faisait des deux est et elle voyait que
j'étais toujours dans le débat dans la
recherche d'explications toujours dans
que don dans le défense et dix autres
retraits puis un jour à madisson son
mari était prof de maths dans le lycée
d'à-côté et elle me dit fier des poulets
secrétaire de section du parti
socialiste à l'époque il me dit est ce
que tu voudrais pas venir une réunion
s'est tenue à quel âge à ce moment là
j'avais 15 ans c'est bien en président
du parti social a concentré dans une rue
une section de parti socialiste même pas
que ça existait alors du coup c'est à ce
moment là donc je suis arrivé il y avait
plein de gens et n'avait aucun qui me
ressemblait donc j'étais là donc je les
écoutais parlé c'était des vieux hommes
non non pas forcément pas maintenant pas
forcément c'est plus vrai aujourd'hui
mais c'est pas forcément à l'époque et
non il y avait de tout c'était
franchement c'était donc un terme
générationnel assez d'accord assez
mélangé et est en fait il me dit j'ai
sous la halle à cette réunion
et quand je suis à restaurer union j'ai
commencé à débattre je me retrouvais
dont le move et débattre des battes des
bottes et puis au final j'y suis resté
et sur le tour n'est parti socialiste
dire que j'ai fait les campagnes
électorales
j'ai aidé les autres à être élu j'ai
distribué des tracts et j'ai collé des
affiches g j'ai fait tout ce que peut
faire un militante de base que
maintenant le certaines ne font plus
passe directement de la case je fais de
la politique à être élu alors qu'en
réalité moi je suis passé sur la case
pendant un long moment où je pensais pas
du tout être élu que je faisais ça parce
que j'y croyais j'étais aussi je me
battais aussi beaucoup contre le
malheureusement la situation de la
drogue
ouais sida la drogue
et donc c'était pour moi aussi un combat
et j'avais peut-être un mois beaucoup de
rage à évacuer et je me suis dit que
c'est finalement le meilleur façon de le
faire c'est parce que je les écoutais
par les jeunes des mêmes séjourna en
fait sont tellement en décalage avec moi
que je sais que c'est ça qui m'a amené à
la politique en ont mais en fait ils
pourront jamais comprendre ce que tu vis
un manque que toi même tu l'expliqués
interventions et j'ai pris un engagement
en ce moment là c'est de ne jamais me
trahir et donc ne jamais trahir les
autres vous avez vous êtes investi en
politique aussi au début un moment où le
front national faisait des gros scores
ouais mais c'est pas ça qui ne sais pas
ça qui vous en aviez posé de questions
non je vais être honnête avec vous c'est
pas du tout ça qui m'a motivé parce que
à l'époque il y avait d'autres
chats à fouetter c'est à dire que je
voulais 10 et j'avais j'avais le combat
contre contre la drogue moi j'ai vu mes
amis mourir d'overdose devant moi j'ai
vu des mamans pleurer parce qu'elle
savait pas comment faire sortir leurs
enfants de la drogue et comment les
accompagner parce que rien est
d'ailleurs toujours aujourd'hui un rien
n'est fait pour aider des jeunes qui
sombre dans la drogue
rien n'est fait pour les accompagner il
ya quasiment plus de psychiatres de
pédopsychiatres de des gens qui peuvent
vous accompagner de médecins spécialisés
il y en a très peu pour avoir des des
endroits où on peut faire des
déclarations de désintoxication des
cours d'eau et tout ça ça a été moi je
comprenais pas j'étais
j'étais comment dire j'étais révoltée de
ça parce que comme vous voyez des amis
moi j'ai perdu 50 % de mes amis certains
est certain aujourd'hui que ceux qui
sont pas morts certains le sida bon il
arrivait encore à vivre en tant mieux et
si je vois qu'ils vivent bien donc tant
mieux mais dont certaines sont encore
sous subutex puisque c'est donc je
connais bien ce sujet là et le fait
qu'on puisse pas apporter de l'aide
un as a man ça me révolte quoi il nous
21e siècle
et ça reste un combat du coût important
important je combats le trafic mais je
combats aussi et j'essaie de faire
expliquer que justement et bien il faut
il faut leur apporter des moyens pour
qu'on aide ceux qui veulent s'en sortir
on fait plein de choses pour que vous
fumez pour arrêter de fumer mais en fait
rien pour arrêter de prendre la coque
fumée
des joints quand on est accro malgré
tout parce que même ceux qui pensent
qu'ils sont pas pour mais quand on se
réveille le matin on a besoin de fumer
ces deux joints de se coucher le soir en
ayant fumé ces deux jeux s'est joint
aussi c'est bien quelque part il ya une
nécessité un besoin voilà du coup il ya
deux sujets actuellement on a parlé du
de l'expérimentation sur le cannabis
thérapeutique mais c'est un autre sujet
sur le débat sur la dépénalisation c'est
quelque chose sur lequel vous avez une
station service complètement moi je suis
complètement contre mais pas de manière
d une partie du parti socialiste qui est
plutôt complet mais moi je suis plutôt
partie je sais vous l'avez quitté
l'année dernière on va en reparler donc
mais mais mais chacun a le droit d'être
pour ou contre moi j'veux pas de
problème moi je dis puisque la question
mais
mais poser je suis contre la
légalisation
du cannabis parce que je considère que
d'abord c'est un faux débat parce
qu'aujourd'hui même s'il savait les
cigarettes aujourd'hui elle est en vente
libre
on est d'accord en tous cas n'aurait pas
acheté votre signal comment vous
expliquer qu'on a le plus gros trafic de
cigarettes en france des cigarettes de
contrebande de cigarettes de contrebande
de cigarettes qui est complètement coupé
qui est très mauvaise qualité
c'est pas le prix du tabac peut-être le
prix du tabac mais pourquoi le prix du
tabac parce que derrière vous avez des
taxes et si demain vous légaliser le
cannabis vous aurez les mêmes taxes vous
aurez les mêmes les mêmes problématiques
que ça changera rien et vous en plus
dans et en plus que dans dans le dans le
cannabis c'est que c'est qu'on est quand
même en france et des règles et donc on
va conditionner le taux donc de l'auteur
thc à l'intérieur du cannabis qui fera
que de toute manière vous serez on sera
au taquet et ceux qui cher et il parle
déjà d'une surtout qu'ils recherchent
finalement ce qui va les faire planer
c'est sûr que si je suis pas convaincu
que ce soit dans ce qu'ils vont acheter
chez à la pharmacie au commerce je ne
sais jouent alors peut-être que ceux qui
prônent la légalisation du cannabis sont
poussés par des lobbyistes certainement
peut-être aussi pour chercher de ce côté
penser ça je suis quand même que il ya
baca dans le chat qui vous dit la
légalisation ne va pas mettre dans une
situation encore plus complexe les
personnes vivant directement ou
indirectement de la vente de drogue
ne faudrait-il pas dépénalisées non
parce que dans ce cas il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui que c'est scott alan j'ai
pas fini c'est vrai mais c'est un faux
débat parce que aura été aujourd'hui
ceux qui vendent de la drogue
ils ont très bien compris c'est des
professionnels de la délinquance des
vrais professionnels croyez moi ces
chefs d'entreprises et on n'a pas
affaire à des distances et des chefs
d'entreprises eux qui l'ont comprise ont
ils ont diversifié leurs offres
notamment à travers la cocaïne la
cocaïne aujourd'hui rapporte autant que
le cannabis donc ces vieux qu'eux mêmes
sont légalisés c'est pour ça que je veux
surtout pas qu'on dise que en égalisant
on règle la question de la sécurité
parce que c'est faux ces fonds et c'est
même plus aggravant je dirai pas ce que
ce qui se passait quand vous avez
affaire d'affaires à des chefs
d'entreprise
mais ils vont développer et ils vont
donner le goût et l'envi à des plus
jeunes de toucher à la cocaïne et voir à
l'héroïne qui revient avec force aussi
donc moi c'est excusez moi mais c'est
finalement ce que j'ai vécu ce que j'ai
connu
et comme je sais ce que ça fait je vous
assure que j'aimerais pas le voir
revenir de manière aussi forte que ce
que j'ai pu connaître côté je
m'attendais pas à ce qu on lance un
débat avec vous sur la dépénalisation
mais deux mais tant mieux c'est un sujet
très intéressant
non mais très bien il ya mln qui dès
qu'il dit mais est-ce que la
dépénalisation ne permettrait pas une
meilleure prévention comme ce qui se
passe au portugal par exemple
non parce qu'aujourd'hui on à la
situation est trop avancée en français
d'abord on est premiers consommateurs
oui c'est vrai rappelez vous savez le
premier consommateur dans le monde que
la différence c'est que aujourd'hui
encore une fois plus on va parler de
l'égalisation de cannabis plus en de la
question de la lequel la cocaïne et
l'héroïne se développe c'est quelque
chose qu'on a observés au portugal par
exemple je sais pas ce que je sais pas
je ne sais pas mais je crois qu'il ya
même des endroits où sévit reviennent en
arrêt ils reviennent en arrière parce
qu'il s'aperçoit que finalement c'est
pas aussi mais en tout cas moi je parle
de ce qu'il ya c'est dire que si on
croit que c'est ça qui va régler le
problème de la délinquance ou le trafic
malheureusement ça ne réglera pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut savoir dans une
cité vous avez chaque bâtiment si je
peux me permettre de dire ainsi chaque
groupe a sa propre
substance et vend sa production donc
finalement ça ne réglera pas et je veux
encore la question de moi je comprends
que que je pense que sur cette question
là il faut pas moi je veux pas être dans
un débat d'abord parce que pour contre
de cette façon là je pense qu'il faut
rentrer dans les caisses que ça apporte
d'être pour qu'est ce que ça apporte si
on dépénalise qu'est ce que ça apporte
si on dépénalise pas et surtout c'est ça
qui vous accord parce que notamment
notamment sur la prévention
aujourd'hui ami quelqu'un qui fume un
joint c'est interdit par la loi donc un
enfant moi j'ai des enfants je n'ai 4-1
donc et je pense que je peux vous dire
c'est que si quand vous avez un enfant
mineur qui fument
s'il a arrêté par la police ils sont
obligés d'appeler vos parents ça permet
aux parents de savoir que l'enfant fume
parce qu'elle peint de parents
malheureusement qui passe à côté s'en
rend même pas compte que leur enfant
film parce que c'est pas facile à
reconnaître
je savais qu'ils sont l'exemple s'est
passé pas vrai parce qu'il faut savoir
que vous avez des pupilles dilatées pas
tout le monde s'est regardé puis de ses
enfants voir sens donc c'est pas non
plus mange connais pas ce que parce que
j'ai j'ai grandi avec ça donc je sais
repérer mais je suis quand même
malheureusement il ya plein de parents
qui ne savent pas qu'ils ne savent pas
repéré et que si on légalise ça veut
dire que 10 on a des enfants qui fument
déjà à la cigarette si finalement on dit
que le cannabis c'est pas si grave que
ça et que on peut le fumé faut savoir
que notamment marcel rufo qui est qui et
donc les 2 6 4 qui est reconnu me dise
amiens tu as raison parce que là le
cannabis on pourrait s'en servir pour
des clans détecter des schizophrénies
des enfants qui sont qui ont une faute
au logis de schizophrènes le cannabis
peut montrer que cet enfant
effectivement est sujette chose alors
ben justement s'il faut pas d'être
pénalisé c'est une mauvaise chose
d'accord pas ce que ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui combien d'enfants
aujourd'hui la question de la
schizophrénie la question aussi grave et
que sa grâce à dame et surtout le
cannabis tu des neurones constitue sa
nurserie ça ne revient plus donc chez un
adolescent ça peut être prêt alors pas
quand on est adulte mais chez
l'adolescent en pleine croissance
ça peut être très dangereux j'aurais
qu'on revienne à vous vous êtes
sénatrice vous êtes sénatrice depuis 11
ans maintenant et il ya une actualité en
ce moment au sénat pour le meilleur ou
pour le pire c'est la question du voile
en mairie d'actualité au sénat son
actualité
tous les médias j'ai enfin moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on en sortira jamais de
ce débat je suis je suis né en 88 et en
89 c'est l affaire de creil
aujourd'hui en 2019 et j'ai l'impression
qu'on est toujours pas sorti de ce débat
non ça vous étonne vous continuez en
parieurs 2019 ou pas oui moi sa méthode
nous 21e siècle se poser des questions
de cette façon là d'abord moi je suis
pour moi je suis parti n'est pas par
principe vous savez moi je suis
quelqu'un qui vous reprenez la la
liberté de chacun d'eux fut de vivre de
s'habiller et des d'expekt faire ce
qu'il veut voilà ça s'appelle la liberté
ça s'appelle de respecter l'autre dans
sa liberté mais de me respecter aussi
dans la mienne et il est le port je pas
force je suis pas une défenseuse du port
du voile pas ma conception mais pour
autant au nom de quoi
maintenant il va falloir qu'on définisse
entre scott en france en dix ans mais
cette maman elle peut pas les amener
accompagner son enfant en sortie
scolaire
alors justement porte foulard au nom de
quoi vous siéger au sein de la
commission culture et éducation au sénat
qui à partir d'hier a commencé à
examiner
vous êtes et ce matin soit un acte à
examiner le projet de loi la proposition
de loi pardon qui a été déposée et qui
vise à interdire le voile pour les
mamans qui accompagnent les sorties
scolaires
tout le monde a l'air divisé au sénat
sur ces questions là au sein même des
groupes politiques tout le monde ait pas
d'acte j'ai vu ça j'ai vu sache vous
avez bien raison de dire ça parce que
vous soyez à gauche que vous soyez à
droite il ya une division way au centre
j'ai vu même du parti communiste
des des choses qui était dit j'ai été
assez surprise quand je parle un peu
surprise mais bon c'est comme ça
ç'a permis peut-être dès que ça permet
aussi clarifier les positions des uns et
des autres c'est à dire à géométrie
variable voyez là ce qu'on dit quand on
est à l'extérieur il ya ce qu'on dit
quand on est à l'intérieur
mais sur cette question là moi je veux
je veux je veux je suis triste je suis
triste parce que je trouve que on
appelle ce pas finalement les choses au
contraire on les les aliments dont léon
les excite et encore une fois une maman
qui quelques fines maman est-ce que les
deux mamans qui accompagnent des enfants
pas son enfant parce que faut arrêter de
dire qu'elle accompagne son enfant elle
accompagne m
les enfants lacombe a de la classe moi
je suis une maman m'est arrivé d'aller
en sortie
scolaire de sorte d'accompagner mon fils
je vais pas souvent mais je lui fais pas
ce que je voulais pas que mon fils se
sentent seulement parce que sa maman
était scénarisé pas toujours à la maison
qu'elle partage pas ces moments et pour
moi c'est des moments aussi importants
de la vie des saints portant des moments
importants de la vie d'une maman ou un
papa d'accompagner à ces sorties
scolaires son enfant et donc ses enfants
mais moi quand je suis arrivé quand j'ai
m'est arrivé de le faire d'abord il ya
un coupon quand vous avez des enfants on
vous dit est ce que vous autorisez votre
enfant sortir pour aller au cinéma pour
aller au musée avec la classe ça veut
dire qu'on considère bien qu'on n'est
plus dans le cadre vraiment scolaire
parce que l'enseignant me demande pas
mon autorisation pour faire faire des
maths du français à mon enfant du couple
vous y tenez je comprends l'argument
mais voilà là on me demande
l'autorisation de pouvoir mais mon
enfant sait bien que c'est pas
obligatoire dans la cadre de la
scolarité
il ya un débat mais c'est justement là
truc se pose le débat à la salle cadre
juridique donc moi quand j'ai amené mon
enfant quand j'ai accompagné la classe
je n'ai en aucun moment je n'ai
participé à l'aspect pédagogique de sa
sortie je n'ai fait que faire en sorte
que l'enfant baisse il traverse bien au
passage piéton que des voitures ne
vienne ne pas perturber le passage que
personne ne vienne d'extérieur se mettre
au milieu des enfants
je me suis occupé de la sécurité des
enfants et ils m'ont rôle et c'est l
enseignante café son rôle d'enseignante
dans la pédagogie de l'enfant donc en
calmant ac
à quel moment la maman qui a parce
qu'elle a un foulard elle va perturber
finalement la pédagogie de l'enfant
c'est ça qui est pas c'est qu'on joue la
perversité dans cette affaire c'est que
ces deux importants et vivien
sincèrement ce qui va se passer nous
rappeler de sorties scolaires parce que
quand on dit ah mais les français sont
d'accord à 60%
mais est ce qu'on dit aux français est
ce qu'on dit aux mamans qui ne peuvent
pas prendre l'air tt est ce qu'on dit
aux mamans qui ne peuvent pas tout
simplement parce qu'elles n'ont pas la
possibilité de première tétée pascal
noël 13 sont obligés d'aller travailler
parce qu'elles n'ont pas elle se remarie
n'ont pas la possibilité d'accompagner
leurs enfants
est-ce que vous acceptez que vos enfants
dans ce cas-là nay pleut en sorties
extrascolaires
est ce que c'est ça la question qu'il
faut poser faut poser les vraies
questions
et puis quand tu fais la grève des
cantines scolaires moi j'ai vu des
mamans demandé à la maman voilée de
voeux
rires si elle pouvait récupérer l'enfant
pendant la période de cantine scolaire
parce qu'elle elle travaillait et
qu'elle ne pouvait pas garder leurs
enfants parce qu'il n'y a pas forcément
les papys et mamies et parce que quand
on l'agly à des grèves mais on est bien
content d'avoir l'ami la maman du petit
garçon du petit caux de la petite copine
qui gardent l'enfant et non se pose pas
de questions si elle porte le foulard du
coup il ya une forme d'hypocrisie selon
vous ou sur des ballerines et c'est quoi
je pense quand je pense qu'on pose pas
bien les questions je pense qu'on n'a
pas bien posé la question aux français
parce que si on dit aux français
est ce que finalement vous préfériez
qu'il n'y ait plus de sorties tant pis
plutôt que d'avoir une maman qui parce
qu'elle a une foulard accompagne ce que
ce n'est pas le sont pas dit cependant
pas des sorcières c'est des mamans et
qu'ils s'occupent de leurs enfants
souvent qu'ils sont élitistes d'ailleurs
je regarde un peu s'il ya un débat dans
le chatt actuellement justement sur ce
sujet là il ya et il y à bakar en fait
qui pose la question de savoir est ce
que c'est vraiment un acte libres de
porter le voile c'est oui c'est un acte
de liberté
c'est un acte de liberté bon je
considère qu au nom de quoi alors
pourquoi je sais pas moi porter des
lunettes vous pouvez mettre des
lentilles pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
opérer pour vous mettez pas démenti
apporté du lot c'est un acte vivre un
moment faut arrêter
non mais je crois qu'il se dit que je me
dis quelque chose que vous les de
l'armée mais je veux dire oui mais c'est
même si un dispositif vous avez raison
médicale n'aurait pas dû prendre il ya
quand même nom mais on aurait aimé mais
jugé un moment au nom de quoi
d'abord défi qu'il le faut arrêter de
croire qu'elles le font parce qu'elles
sont opprimés obligé c'est pas vraiment
je vois des mamans qui ont mon âge qui
ont des filles qui ont 18 ans 20 ans 25
ans qui porte le foulard et pourtant les
mamans je peux vous dire qu'elles ne
sont pas du tout là dedans
donc elles n'ont pas été éduqués à ça et
comment vous expliquez que dans une même
famille vous avez celle qui va avoir le
foulard vous avez une autre qui va pas
qui va être fashion victim
voilà non monsieur je donc en neige
entre les autres liaisons qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec vous vous opposeront
le communautarisme le fait qu'il ya des
règles religieuses qui s'impose est que
choisir de se respecter une règle
religieuse n'est pas faire acte de
liberté que la liberté c'est
l'émancipation par rapport aux règles
religieuses aussi et c'est les mêmes et
c'est les même pour certains notamment
pour la droite c'est les mêmes qui
étaient contre le mariage pour tous qui
ont manifesté pour dire que parce qu'ils
aient les mêmes qui vont à l'église
et c'est les mêmes qui sont à attendait
avant j'en ai aussi entendre tout ça
mais moi je n'arrête pas de me parler de
deux mois je mens je suis je suis une
forte troisièmement profondément laïque
vous me trouverez nulle part dans à
défaut là dessus donc j'ai pas de
problème avec ça
mais justement parce que j'ai pas de
problème mais d'ailleurs c'est c'est
souvent d'ailleurs seulement je veux
dire quand je vois que quand on va dans
les et moi je sais pas il m'arrive de
faire je fais la procession parce que sa
vie à marseille on bénit religieuses
notamment saint pierre parce que c'est
une tradition marseillaise pour les
pêcheurs et pour que la mère abondent et
protège les pêcheurs et les passants
donc apporte beaucoup de poissons et
protège des pêcheurs
donc quand je fais ça je ne sens pas je
le fais je le fais aussi dans une
tradition plus une tradition que dans
une aspects religieux pourtant il ya le
puits ya le curé qui l'a jamais vraiment
je me détache de tout ça il ya le curé
je considère je respecte
pourquoi ça serait hélas quand je vois
par contre tous les élus et du front
national et de droite et qui se prennent
riquet prennent aussi et qui font la
prière et qui se met à genoux et ja pas
de souci un fait moche et ça ne pose
aucun problème à presser leurs droits
c'est leur liberté
et pourquoi je vais pourquoi dans ce cas
là nous allons par contre la femme qui
elle parce qu'elles portent un foulard
évidemment mais qui c'est qui qui
finalement pas le libre c'est
intéressant quand vous êtes en train de
revenir sur un clivage droite gauche
alors que tout allait on était d'accord
vous et moi pour dire que c'est y
compris au sein de la gauche vous avez
parlé du pcf par exemple où certains
élus aussi sont pas d'accord les uns et
les autres entre une conception laïque
traditionnel anticlérical clairement et
donc anti voile d'une certaine manière
mais sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est la droite
qui la composent cette équipe aux 7 pp a
lancé quand même cas sinon je vais vous
avez raison parce qu'un méchant
oui mais elle divise mais pascal oblige
à les obligeons au débat mais moins
qu'on ait un débat sur cette question
mange pas de problème pour qu'on ait un
débat et je pense que c'est toujours
bien d'avoir des défauts des voix posée
et je défends ma position parce que je
suis parce que je trouve qu'on est en
train d'amener les français parce que ce
sont des français malgré tout et avant
tout voilà on les amène dans des débats
qui ne sont pas et moi j'aimerais bien
vous regardez regardez en replay s'il
vous plaît l'assemblée nationale il me
semble qu'il ya des députés qui portent
des grosse croix à l'assemblée nationale
on les a jamais sorti on les a jamais
sortis de l'hémicycle parce qu'ils
avaient des grosses crois et je les ai
vus dans les plateaux télé et je les ai
vus partout alors dites-moi si peut-être
d'autres avaient mais non mais ça ou
sinon c'est à géométrie variable cette
histoire c'est un jour mais très
variable par contre quand y mènent quand
ils mènent des combats au nom de
l'église
oh non mais c'est leur droit à la limite
ils ont le droit s'ils sont croyants que
de penser qu' il faut pas là la paix est
mal gpa est un endroit mais au nom de
quel droit ils le font si ce n'est au
nom d'une religion l'armée donc donc
donc c'est libérer ça c'est vous dire là
ça devient le débat là c'est le débat
parce que c'est porté par l'église
catholique
exemple une spécifique sur des
musulmanes il ya un problème avec les
musulmans clamant je veux pas le
prélèvement ou avec l'un est un problème
avec les musulmans
le cas bien dia des premiers à dire
qu'on ne supporte plus en france le
monde politique
voilà je ne supporte plus les musulmans
ça c'est pas les musulmans qui ont un
problème c'est comme en politique
aujourd'hui la sueur mais je pense que
je pense que aujourd'hui ça ça mène pas
de faire moi je trouve que c'est nul
parce que sincèrement avec la les vrais
problèmes qu'on a dans nos liens
madame
ben dhia ben dhia tél oui il a notamment
dit elle dans les collèges
elle va dans les lycées elle va avec
quoi c'est là c'est la maman de la
victime de main mais ne verra que
mohamed merah qui est typiquement du
militaire ll aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
fait de la prévention est la plus grande
et la plus grande des religieuses elles
et avec elle et elle est voilée et porte
et pour autant c'est la plus grande
républicaine que je connaisse parce
qu'elle défend la république française
elle défend elle défend finalement une
forme de l'elfe la laïcité elle défend
justement il combat le terrorisme
et cette dame là quand elle va dans les
lycées alors qu'elle est voilée la
personne qui lui dit qu'elle n'a pas le
droit
alors on va lui dire demain qu'elle ne
pourrait rien ne pourra plus y aller et
l'auvergnate qui nous fait remarquer qu'
elle dit elle même que celle que le
voile est pour elle un signe de deuil
c'est vrai en plus à la raison c'est
vrai parce que souvent les femmes quand
elles perdent un enfant mari et un
proche elle met d'abord j'aime pas ce
terme de voile foulard parce que d'abord
c'est même pas le voile parce que le
voile c'est en général quelque chose
qu'on met devant et pas et pas sur la
couleur sur le chemin que c'est
important parce que même s intéressant
qu'elle est la sémantique et les
piégeurs et piégés
mais vous avez parlé donc on vous avait
parlé du problème qu'on a collectivement
avec les musulmans qu en tout cas la
scène politique et peut-être médiatique
avec les musulmans
il ya aussi quelque chose en cette
rentrée qui s'est passé c'est que le
président de la république a décidé de
parler d'immigration jeu quand les pl
quand dans les pays arabes nous verrons
des églises et les cathédrales se
construire et non pas se détruire mais
moi je suis d'accord mais moi je croyais
encore je crois que c'est pas il faut
pas tout mélanger et je peux vous dire
que beaucoup de musulmans et notamment
je les arabes de coptes avec qui j'étais
d'ailleurs encore dimanche j'étais avec
le pape copte est qu'est venu et qui se
déplace très rarement sa première fois
qu'il venait en france mais j'étais là
parce que j'étais justement en soutien
et moi je n'ai justement je ne demande
pas les uns contre les autres je
considère quand je parle de liberté je
suis sûr que je suis honnête dans cette
danse est un plagiat parce que justement
ne jamais cesser pas et c'est pas parce
qu'on est musulman en france qu' on est
d'accord avec le fait qu'on puisse faire
du mal à des gens qui ne sont pas
musulmans bien au contraire les premiers
d'ailleurs qu'ils vivent qui souffrent
du du terrorisme sont souvent les
musulmans eux mêmes
je range en revient quand même à ce s il
ya quand même le las a été donné en
cette rentrée par emmanuel macron qui a
décidé de mettre sur le devant de la
scène l'immigration il ya eu un débat au
sénat
ça n'a rien à voir annoncée n'a rien à
voir dans le fond dans le fond du débat
on sait qu'en france quand on parle
d'immigration très rapidement on parle
d'intégration et pour tout une partie
notamment de la droite assez rapidement
on parle de l'islam et ce qui n'a pas
aussi un rôle joué par le gouvernement
là dedans non je crois que franchement
je crois que on peut
je crois qu'il ya deux choses on peut
parler de l'immigration et après et je
pense qu'il ya deux sujets la question
du foulard de la maman qui porte un
foulard pour qu'alain compagnon son
enfant à l'école je vois pas en quoi
celle là l'est en france elle vit en
france et des françaises ses impôts en
france donc va de l'autre côté on parle
d'immigration mais d'immigration ça n'a
rien à voir c'est deux choses
différentes que on règle la question
d'immigration et qu'on se dise qu'il ya
un problème
oui d'immigration et qu'il faut qu'on
regarde de quelle façon on puisse le
régler et que ça se passe en france mais
aussi dans les pays où l'immigration de
l'immigration vient mais moi je suis
complètement favorable à sa mère nocar
et d'un problème avec l'immigration
pourrait le définir selon vous c'est
quoi le problème de l'immigration je
veux pas qu'on mélange que l'immigration
m'emmerder qui savez moi je suis né
justement j'étais né à marseille mais
moi mes parents soient m ma mère est
arrivée à 3 ans mes grands parents sont
ses grands parents j'ai été levée par
mes grands parents qui parlent qui
parlait pas un mot de français quand ils
sont arrivés ils sont man il parlait pas
un mot de français quand ils sont morts
voilà donc et pour autant il était
respectueux de la république française
il était aux pratiquants et ils n'ont
jamais
poser problème et encore mieux m'ont mis
dans une école de bonnes choses de
bonnes soeurs catholiques en sachant que
faisait le catéchisme donc un don qui ça
n'a pas posé de problème parce que
manquant
c'était une richesse et donc ça veut
dire idée comme ça il y en a beaucoup
heureusement et c'est la majorité et
après faut pas regarder la minorité de
personnes qui peut avoir un foulard et
cas le droit de le porter si elle le
désire après bien sûr il faut faire
attention et s'il ya des filles quand on
oblige à se couvrir à ce moment là il
faut mettre des structures peut-être qui
dans lesquelles elles peuvent comme vous
savez un peu
comme on appelle ça de l'est revenir les
plannings familiaux peut-être des
structures alors comme des plannings
familiaux où les personnes peuvent aller
peut-être expliquer dire voilà on me de
quelle façon je suis enfin je suis amusé
par mes parents où on m'oblige et voir
de quelle façon peu les pouvoirs publics
peuvent l'accompagner et l'aider et je
crois que ça c'est important
c'est important mais vous allez
peut-être il faut un peu plus développés
où les fils les foyers des foyers du
jeune fille moi j'ai connu à mon époque
est bénéfique on voulait marier de
l'office qui se battaient pour
puisqu'elle ne souhaitait pas être marié
avec quelqu'un qu'elle ne connaissait
pas et qu'elle n'aimait pas belle partie
dans des foyers
elle était elle faisait leur vie et puis
des fois leur venaient parce que les
parents avaient comprise avaient évolué
tant que c'est ça qu'il faut
mais qu'il faut regarder à bichon qui
vous dit merci de faire la différence
entre la question migratoire et la
question religieuse slash musulmane
c'est assez rare pour être souligné
effectivement il ya en tout cas de vous
défendez fortement l'idée que la
question migratoire et la question de
l'islam sont deux choses différentes
mais complètement sur l'immigration vous
êtes favorable à des quotas est depuis
longtemps une censure départ ça c'est
quoi ta d'immigration pour vous parce
que je pense que savez moi justement
parce que je suis une enfant d'immigrés
je sais combien comme vous arrivez enfin
même si moi je suis né là mais j'ai vu
mes parents j'ai mangé dit j'ai vécu
dans un bidonville dans des dans des
conditions j'ai pas de salle de bains
n'avait pas de vraiment jeu on vivait
comme si moi j'ai vécu je suis né en
france mais j'ai vécu comme si j'étais
dans un village berbère 1
donc à partir de là je dis juste que
quand on est quand on doit accueillir
des immigrés il faut bien le faire il
faut bien le faire parce que c'est pour
ça il faut voir les capacités que nous
avons le faire s combien de logements
nous pouvons leur mettre à disposition
combien de places dans les écoles comme
bien est-ce que derrière on peut faire
une insertion professionnelle de
formation
c'est tout ça à qu'elle accompagnera
quel accompagnement nous apportons la
question sanitaire parce que là aussi il
ya un vrai sujet donc toutes ces
questions là par pas d'essayer une
immigration arrivée qu'on ne maîtrise
plus qui arrive dans tous les sens il ya
les migrants moche que la différence
continue entre la famille mais gris qui
vient parce que l est
opressé politiquement dans le pays les
réfugiés les réfugiés politiques ça
c'est encore autre chose voilà
ensuite vous avez ceux qui viennent
parce qu'ils ont parce que la question
aussi dans le voit avec les déluges qui
est ce que la création la question
climatique et de jets économique aussi
voilà qui est une réalité on voit la
question et après vous avez ceux qui en
ont fait un trafic les passeurs les
passeurs voilà moi je pense qu'il faut
être très sévère avec les passeurs il
faut être très sévère parce qu'il met en
danger la vie de deux truies on n'est
pas assez aujourd'hui comment on n'est
pas assez aujourd'hui c'est leur
épaisseur à écouter non non je vous jure
sincèrement parce que de l'autre côté on
a et c'est eux qui on a aussi une
organisation de prostitution
ces chartes migrants et ils sont
nombreux le problème c'est un problème
de laxisme c'est une question moyens
c'était compliqué de démonter pas
spécialement non mais c'est mais même
quand ils sont en france quand ce sont
en france qu'il ya des réseaux de
prostitution des procédés réseau de
drogue des trafics de drogue des réseaux
de trafic de subutex savez aujourd'hui
qu'il ya du trafic de subutex
ouais fortement mais voilà donc c'est
dramatique en situation d'un point de
vue sanitaire mais on est bien d'accord
donc c'est dramatique et son cto ces
questions là il faut les un compte
il faut il faut pas avoir peur de les
mettre sur la table pour dire oui nous
avons ce sujet comment on fait donc moi
je dis oui la maman que la famille qui
va venir avec ses enfants mais il faut
aider les enfants faut accompagner et ça
peut être une réussite et une chance
même pour la france mais pour autant à
un moment il faut dire voilà nous on est
là france est de combien on peut en
accueillir et vraie vie et par ville
aussi cogné enfin accueillir et comment
comment on peut s'en occuper et de
manière réelle donc ses lecteurs mais le
débat attendant trois générations pour
que les faire s'intégrer et encore dés
fois dans des conditions et on les voit
aujourd'hui déplorable mais donc ces
quotas si on les met en place son effet
sur quels critères s'est coincé par
branche professionnelle parce qu'il faut
le faire par branche professionnelle
il faut le faire aussi par d'abord
permettre aux étudiants aussi de venir
étudier en france pour ceux qui le
souhaitent
parce que je pense c'est une richesse
aussi donc les frais d'inscription
pas forcément pour augmenter pour les
augmenter du tout voilà je pense que
quand on a trois conséquences ionel vous
a donné raison d'ailleurs exactement
moi je suis très contente je je je pense
que oui sur la question excusez moi des
quotas migratoires vous ai dit ok
laisser les étudiants venir étudier et
ensuite c'est quoi aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il ya des professions qui ne sont pas
pourvus parce que tout simplement en
france le français il ya des métiers qui
n'a plus envie de faire ou que parce que
les cdt l'immigration déjà de mes grands
parents s'ils sont venus parce que parce
qu'il y avait des avait du boulot et que
surtout parce qu'il y avait des métiers
que les français déjà voulez-vous que ne
voulait plus avoir à changer les métiers
10h10 c'étaient les italiens des
espagnols qui avaient plus envie parce
qu'ils sont intégrés que ceux là ont
compris sa phase d'étude
il n'avait plus envie de faire ce métier
donc ça a été les maghrébins qui l'ont
fait le sénégalais est ensuite
maintenant ben la maintenance et cela
ils ont plus envie parce qu'ils ont
aussi fait des études ils ont évolué et
contrairement à ce qu'on croit et
devrait donc y à la place à ceux qui
arrivent et qui peuvent occuper certains
certaines professions mais pas que là on
en avait besoin aussi dans la médecine
puisque d'ailleurs on récupère aussi
chez notamment ils arrivent beaucoup de
médecins parce que la france manque de
métier impossible
bon maintenant le numerus clausus à
sauter mais s'est bien rattrapé le saas
est votre position par l décalage
nécessaire
alors il ya une question très
intéressant de baca qui va me permettre
de faire la transition vos idées vos
idées sont elles partagées par le reste
du groupe socialiste samia ghali
j'ai du mal à vous placer politiquement
c'est un chéquier
vous avez vous allez nous expliquer
parce que vous avez été longtemps au
parti socialiste vous l'avez quittée
l'an dernier vous siégez actuellement au
sein du groupe socialiste au sénat
vous avez l'air d'être assez d'accord
avec en marche sur la question de
l'immigration
vous avez d'ailleurs été invités au pot
de rentrée de vos collègues en marche au
sénat et en même temps en 2017
vous vous disiez franchement proche de
jean luc mélenchon si je vais vous dire
c'est alors expliquez moi vous êtes tout
à gagner alors je vais vous dire j'ai
comme ça on va clarifier ont clarifié
les choses vous allez me permettre
d'abord j'étais quand j'étais au parti
socialiste
j'ai démarré je n'ai pas dit mais la
gauche socialiste avec jean luc
mélenchon je savais pas vous voyez c'est
pas tout allez jean luc mélenchon julien
dray marie noëlle lienemann
donc c'est vrai que j'ai grandi
intellectuellement tusa a vécu est
d'abord et d'ailleurs la question des
quotas était porté à la gauche
socialiste est vrai par la gauche
socialiste et aujourd'hui de la porte
plus fraîche je sais pas j'ai pas posée
mélenchon si vous nous regardez
ouais non mais j'en sais rien mais
peut-être mais c'était pas vraiment lui
c'était julien dray l'agent qui dans
tous les sens mais j'étais déjà d'accord
avec lui à l'époque
donc voyez je mets en a pas un défaut on
peut sur sur moi je me pose
après c'est vrai que sur mélenchon
cependant incapable d présidentielle je
trouve qu'il avait bien poser les choses
je rappelle que mélenchon est un élu
marseille a depuis 2010 est depuis 2008
marseillais mais les plus parisiens à
marseille du parisien marseille n'est
pas parti des peines et du parrain
marseillais tany pas désamorcée oui mais
il est un élu parisien a marseille il
n'est jamais amorcé
d'accord d'accord voilà je pense que
voulait dire ok donc c'est non non ça
c'est un petit tacle mais je n'en sais
pas un tacle c'est granit et non mais
c'est une réalité attendait sa merci
mais six mois pour pas non mais qui sont
parachutés pourquoi pas les moindres
je suis plus à ça près mais quand on est
élu son territoire sur tout un
territoire il est dans le territoire
dans des pauvres de marseille
ben c'est normal qu'on soit il doit y
être présent et quand on n'est pas là
pendant six mois
moi j'ai pas comment il fait pour ne pas
être présent dans sa circonscription
pendant six mois je sais mon mais
c'était pas du tout ni un tacle non mais
vous étiez quand même d'accord avec lui
en 2017 il vous a séduit sa campagne non
ça séduit et sa campagne m'a séduite par
ce que j'ai vu je les veux observer je
vais vous raconter je vais vous dire une
confidence j'ai eu une opération très
lourde et donc j'étais aussi faire
injecter alité et donc j'ai vraiment
suivi pendant cette période là les
débats à la télé donc ils étaient
nombreux et donc j'ai vu évoluer
jean luc mélenchon pendant la
présidentielle et je voyais ces ciment
même lui dans son évolution dans sa
façon de présenter les choses
une vraie évolution je partirai pas je
partageais pas tout j'ai pas dis j'ai
dit que je j'avais des points avec
lesquels je pouvais me retrouver avec
jean luc mélenchon mais c'est vrai
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs en jeu je jette
pas tout de ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon faut pas non plus voilà
mais sûr
mais ça ne m'empêche pas moins d'être ya
longtemps que j'ai pris le parti mais
déjà quand je suis dit j'étais au parti
socialiste avait toujours pris le parti
de je vous ai dit que je je me mettais
sur l'aspect des gens et de la réalité
de terrain et j'essaie de ne pas me
déclare d'état détacher de ça et c'est
dur quand vous faites de la politique
surtout à un niveau parce qu'on vous
oblige rentrer dans une case de surtout
ne pas bouger de surtout être toujours
en lien avec votre ligne du votre groupe
de votre parti ce qui les avait jamais
mais les classes vous pas votre truc
c'est pas mon truc qui suivait bien et
si j'avais aimé ça aujourd'hui je serais
pas là c'est pas faux voilà parce que je
n'étais pas fait pour être sénatrice il
y avait rien qui le prédestinait à être
là où je suis et du coup je repose ma
question vous êtes où là c'est ben je
suis je suis là vous mais là où vous
posez des questions en fonction des
questions que vous posez vous aurez les
réponses c'est quoi sa géométrie
variable où c'est bien beau mais très
variable est ce que vous pensez non je
sais pas vraiment en auvergne
on a parlé du voile j'ai donné ma
position sur le voile mais si je sais au
à la faire vous verrez si ma position
elle est partagée par plus de gens de
gauche bête je serai de gauche si elle
est partagée par plusieurs du centre je
serai du centre et si elle partagé par
plus de gens de droite je serai de
droite mais je mets pas me poser je vais
pas prendre ma paie allez je vais pas
faire ma position me disant attention
faut absolument que je souhaite dans la
gauche où elle a dans la droite et donc
je vais prendre cette position là donc
en fonction des questions que vous me
posez sur certaines thématiques oui vous
me verrez évoluer dans les cases dans
lequel vous pensez qu'il faut être
assurée absolument d'arrêté moi je ne
souhaite pas absolument vous mettre dans
des cases mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que politiquement c'est vrai que
politiquement j'ai traité de maquereaux
nice maman macron bien alors expliquez
moi ça parce que je vous êtes assez
proche de dents marche aujourd'hui en
tout cas lorsque j'entends dans ce que
j'ai lu de vous de vos interviews etc
ça veut dire quoi être ma cronista vent
macron parce que en fait ce que ce
qu'avait fait maquereau en disant il
faut arrêter la france a aussi besoin au
moment de se poser et de regarder les
problèmes en face c'est à dire que moi
je le dis franchement je ne me
positionne jamais sur un sujet en
fonction de savoir si je vais être trop
à droite trop bas il ya plein de choses
que je n'aurais pas dit où
et donc je me serais tuée j'aurais été
dans la langue de bois et j'ai pas envie
d'être dans ce à quoi j'ai pas envie
d'être dans ça je vais pas me mentir je
vais pas mentir à main à mon histoire je
vais pas mentir à jeu s'adresse égérie
de trahir me trahir trahir mon histoire
trahir ce que c'est pourquoi j'ai fait
de la politique sage pas envie de ça et
peu importe que ça me coûte c'est moi ça
m'a coûté cher d'ailleurs c'est vrai
ouais ben oui mais elle m'a pas fait de
cadeau pour ça mais c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave parce que ben après je
suis vous dis encore une fois ça m'a pas
empêchée d'avancer et si je vois là une
vogue la galère
moi je l'assuré qui vous pose la
question vous ne vous considérez pas
comme de gauche je me considère samia
ghali
pourquoi autant pourquoi je sais pas
c'est zurich qui demande à moi
génériques
c'est pourquoi on est obligé vous rendez
compte comme la frustration quand même
de se dire et en plus quand on voit
cette gauche qui émouvante parce que
deux mais de la gauche d'abord de quoi
on parle de quelle gauche celle de
mélenchon du npa celle du parti
socialiste celle de même dans le parti
sous sa moye je sais plus quelle est la
gauche celle des verts c'est là qu'elle
de gauche moi j'en sais rien moi la
gauche aujourd'hui il ya tellement de la
touche
lego la gauche a toujours été pluriel à
tchô été diverses la gauche histoire
mais sauf qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi ils
s'entendent pas parce qu'ils sont mais
il s'en passe donc c'est pas à l'ehpad
pluriel on voit bien qu'elle est capable
de sang pendant le trauma ils sont et
ils ont été ensemble ou non comme
d'habitude non messieurs réunis par
hannibal en tant qu elle s'est plus
réuni la gauchère certain temps et quand
elle s'est réveillée elle pourrait être
serrée niel s'est déchirée en mille
morceaux donc de qu'on parle
arrêtons d'être hypocrite quand même
aussi choisir moi je veux bien qu'on me
dise ça vient gagner on sait pas où vous
situez bête tant mieux si on sait pas me
situer parce que franchement c'est ce
que je souhaite
voilà c'est de ça 2 de me situer là au
moins quand on veut situer samira ben on
regarde le sujet que vous regardez ce
que je voudrais dire aux internautes
regardez le sujet qui vous intéresse qu
vous voyez la réponse que j'ai apportée
et vous verrons je me situe mathias qui
vous demandent macro nisme qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire suivre
tout ce que dit macron annonce à ses
parents que leur semble bien compris abs
av et ar ça veut dire quoi non pas ses
fils dans le dans dans dans la forme
c'est à dire demain dans la méthode
voilà de dire
que je
je suis pas voilà je veux pas qu'on me
mettre dans une case je suis libre je
veux être libre voilà et si le maquereau
nisme c'est être dans plutôt à droite
qu'à gauche et bien je serai pas dans le
maquereau nizam non plus d'accord j'ai
une question très direct pour vous est
ce que vous serez candidate à la mairie
de marseille dans six mois écoutez ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que c'est
une question qui
qui est dans mon esprit très fortement
mais moi je voudrais pas la pause et de
cette façon là j'aime ma ville j'aime ma
ville mais vraiment je laime voilà et
mais quand j'ai dit j'aime ma ville je
la vois aussi souffrir aujourd'hui je
l'avais souffrir dans sa chair
je vois aujourd'hui tout est si de la
situation que ce soit en matière
économique
un tiers de transport en matière de
logement on l'a vu matière d'école
matière environnementale de l'urbanisme
tout c'est tous les maux que subissent
de ville parce que s est ma ville parce
qu'elle est elle est en souffrance et
parce qu'on s'est pas occupé d'elle
personne s'est occupé d'elle elle a pas
eu
elle n'a pas eu un maire à la hauteur de
la deuxième ville de france qui était
capable de s'occuper des suds des
problèmes et d affronter essayer
d'apporter des réponses aux sujets aux
problèmes des marseillais alors oui je
cesserai je ferai tout ce qu'il faut
vraiment je le dis pour jouer forte
alternative à jean claude gaudin aux
joueurs blessés il faut tourner la page
je pense que ça situe d'abord qu'on le
veuille ou non on tournera la page il
sera plus là donc ça se voit c'est une
situation unique sur lequel on peut être
au moins qui vous a prêt-à-porter cette
alternative où vous souhaitez le faire
je je je souhaite le faire je souhaite
le faire je souhaite le faire pour ma
ville je sais peut faire pour vous savez
moi j'ai gêné j'ai des enfants j'en ai
un dernier cas 12 ans et je vous dis
franchement ce que j'ai besoin que cette
ville elle qu'elle de ce qu'elle se
renouvelle mais se renouvelle dans dans
la façon d'être dans la façon de voir la
politique mondiale moi je me suis
toujours occupé de marseille je me suis
toujours occupé de ma ville je me suis
pas réveillé à 6 mois des élections
j'ai pas décidé de faire je sais pas
quoi un collectif un machin pour dire
allez on va partir à la mairie de
marseille
non parce que moi c'est au quotidien que
je me suis occupé de marseille ça au
moins personne peut m'en vais parce que
j'ai toujours défendues mabile partout
et surtout quand je suis à paris je la
défends encore plus parce que souvent vu
de paris on a l'impression vous les
marseillais on prend danse toujours ça à
la blague
non non oui les marseillais c'est aussi
la france marseille c'est un lieu
stratégique aussi pour la france
notamment avec l'europe du sud mais aux
lois de la vie toutes les questions
notamment de l'espagne de l'italie
tout ça la france n 1
stratégique à la grèce la france a le
jeu stratégique
mais au-delà de ça elle a aussi un jeu à
jouer avec la méditerranée elle a un jeu
à jouer avec aussi l'afrique et je crois
que c'est important que justement de
donner à marseille à en faire une vraie
capitale pour que ce soit aussi pour
faire briller la france pour faire
briller la france
est-ce que vous avez des questions pour
samia ghali des dernières questions on
arrive à la fin de cette émission donc
n'hésitez pas sur des questions très
courtes qu'ils appellent des réponses
très courte
moi du coup pour continuer sur sept sur
sept lignes et des munitions c'est pas
c'est pas lui
ses passions la deuxième ville alors je
vois qu'il ya débat dans le chat c'est
quoi de ces bassesses et la deuxième
c'est marseille alors les lyonnais
désolé pour les lyonnais la mais c'est
vrai que j'ai par contre non mais par
contre non non pas parce que je veux pas
être convaincu les mémés de dire que
c'est vrai que lyon a su malheureusement
nous voler la vedette dans un parce
qu'il ya eu effectivement un maire qui a
qui a su faire ce qu'il fallait pour
lyon là où nous voulions a pris
effectivement le rendez-vous nous avions
raté en accusant le regard mais on va
vite vous rattrapez vous inquiétez pas
avec sa galerie peut-être qu'est-ce que
je qu'est ce que je vais dire comment
vous ce que vous voyez
parce que là on marche un peu du mal va
bien à marseille mais je leur dise où
c'est le trio oui j'ai créé j'ai créé un
mouvement qui s'appelle marseille avant
tout justement pour mettre marseille au
coeur de touffes avec le soutien ça la
question
mais j'ai dit que gêné mais tu es jeune
était fermé à rien et je me laisse la
possibilité de parler avec tous et avec
éventuellement de recevoir le parrainage
de la majorité dans un seul et fermer
aucune peur je ne ferme aucune porte
mais pour autant je ne je ne mettrai pas
non plus à genoux j'ai bien compris
un petit point sur l'urbanisme à
marseille l'effondrement rue d'aubagne
était il ya environ un an c'est vrai ça
c'était il ya un an mais le 5 novembre
bientôt malheureusement je n'aime pas le
terme de on fêtera pas ce que parce que
c'est viendra on se souviendra en tout
cas c'est un moment qu'on n'oubliera pas
les marseillais n'oublieront pas ça
c'est sûr un huit morts dans des
conditions atroces j'ai tu avais moi
j'ai en mémoire cet enfant moi j'étais
là le jour où ça s'est effondré le matin
très tôt et ont cherché en scène essayer
de comprendre qu'il y avait dans
l'immeuble qui n'allait pas et il y
avait une maman qui avait moi j'avais la
famille de la maman était là qui me
disait bien accompagner le petit à
l'école on essayé de l'appeler on arrive
pas on n'arrive pas à la joindre
et cet enfant qui était à l'école
primaire qui rentrent le ca matin sa
maman l'accompagné l'école
le soir il est petit on va nous
expliquer que ce non seulement il a
perdu sa maison parce que tout s'est
effondré ya plus de maisons
il a perdu sa maman il a perdu sa vie
parce que c'est parce que comment se
construire quand vous revenez de l'école
et qu' il ne vous reste plus rien il
vous reste plus rien c'est mais moi je
suis je veux dire je m'en parle encore
avec beaucoup d'émotion parce que je
suis une maman et je savais moi je
considère que les enfants c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut plus que protéger comme
si c'est moi je suis une maman poule je
suis voilà et j'ai du mal avec quand je
vois des enfants souffrir c'est quelque
chose avec lequel je ne n'arrive peut
faire que j'ai du mal à vivre et c'est
bon c'est des moments difficiles et mon
jeu oui c'est très beau d'aubagne et que
chacun porte sa responsabilité chacun
doit assumer ce qu'il s'est passé il
faut plus que ça se reproduise
la responsabilité est partagée je veux
même pas rentrer dans les questions de
procédure de savoir leurs
responsabilités je pense que ceux qui
ont laissé faire puisqu'on est haut
niveau sur l'urbanisme et la lutte
contre le nier par owni pas et de ce
point de vue là et de ce point de vue là
oui j'en veux à la majorité municipale
parce que c'est tout ce laxisme vous
savez pendant des années alors je disais
marseille souffre il y en a plein les
souffrances que et bien sûr que y'a pas
à chaque fois une immeubles qui
s'effondrent mais si ça devait se si
l'image ça devait être des immeubles qui
s'effondrent les meubles qui s'effondre
il y en aurait beaucoup beaucoup à
marseille sur la question des écoles sur
tout a été laissé à l'abandon on a
choisi de fractures esteville de la
fracture est soit savez vous avez une
personne sur 3 marseille qui vient au
dessus du seuil de pauvreté
quand on a une ville avec une personne
sur trois qui vient de sus de pauvreté
on essaie d'avoir une ville et menthe
avec une ville savez il faut il faut
être attendre et c'est à dire il faut
s'occuper des marseillais il faut les
regarder font les écouter faut essayer
de trouver avec eux les solutions parce
qu'elle n'a dé solution mais faut-il
avoir envie de les régler est-ce que
vous pensez que notre démocratie
fonctionne bien c'est professeur ou un
habit qui vous demandent si le dégoût
des français je cite pour les
politiciens
est ce que ça ne nous oblige pas à
repenser la façon dont notre démocratie
fonctionne alors je ne sais pas s'il ya
vraiment vous savez sur le terrain c'est
peut-être pas le mot je sais mais je
pense qu'il faut faire attention au
terme de dégoût pour les politiciens
tout ça parce que vous savez on peut
avoir une monarchie aussi un donc mais
tout l'internet suivante et après je
sais pas ce que c'est moi les
alternatives franchement j'ai du mal à
comprendre parce qu'à un moment fou
qu'on arrête des politiques on est élu
par le nez et lui quand même juste par
le peuple
ils ont le droit de choisir des
élections ni remis en question tout le
temps oui l'actrice mythique et mal aimé
on va être d'accord là dessus il ya des
fois un jeu et franchement des fois des
fois de manière disproportionnée aussi
voilà parce que c'est des ailes ça fait
bien de dire qu'on n'aime pas les
politiques c'est devenu à la mode
voilà c est nominé sera dit pas que ça
traduit pas quelque chose de profond ça
quand même parce que franchement eh bien
je vais vous dire une chose prendre un
exemple mais moi je suis maman je suis
une mère de famille j'ai des parents
chez mes parents je vois quasiment pas
mes parents j'ai du mal à voir ce que
j'aime mes amis tout ça parce que je
donne tout à la politique du vendredi
non mais je le dis d'une injustice a dit
non mais ça demande beaucoup mais pour
hossam et non mais toute la semaine
toutes les nuits le week-end je te
prendre un de temps en temps un week end
je pars pas en vacances pendant l'été
j'essaye de prendre des vacances assez
courte c'est une autre vie
parce que tout simplement j'ai tellement
je me sens tellement ces personnes les y
oblige vous me direz mais parce que vous
avez la conscience professionnelle en
tant que politique que je me sens pas de
partir et de me dire que s'il arrive
quelque chose je suis pas là et mon rôle
c'est de et je réponds moi j'ai un
numéro de téléphone
croyez moi à marseille en tant qu adam
ont dans mon secteur
tout le monde a mon numéro de téléphone
celui qui ne veut pas me joindre c'est
qu'il est pas mal même parce que tout
mon amoureuse ça fait 25 ans j'ai le
même numéro
je ne les jamais changé je répondais
fois à minuit à 1h du matin à des gens
qui sont en souffrance en détresse
croyez-moi des situations compliquées
vous l'avez vous avez aussi des gens qui
viennent qui vous raconte tout leur
misère parce que ils n'ont personne à
qui raconter et vous vivez avec ça c'est
à dire avec l' angoisse des gens avec
tout ça parce que des fois vous arrivez
à régler des problèmes des fois que vous
y arrivez pas des fois c'est plus
compliqué il des fois il ya des
souffrances et vous vous avez vous avez
ses souffrances en vous et quand vous
arrivez à la maison je peux vous dire
que vous n'êtes pas disponible pour les
vôtres vous n'êtes pas disponible pour
ceux que vous aimez et ni pour ceux qui
vous aiment et c'est ça et donc un
moment de dire les politiques c'est tous
des pourris et bien un moment quand tu
auras plus de politiques qui n'auront
plus envie de faire ce travail parce
qu'à un moment c'est vrai que c'est bien
d'aider les gens mais quand vous prenez
des clac toute la journée mais peut-être
que la dépose des congères bombe arrêté
et on laissera et pour faire attention
pas ce seront les banques qui partiront
et vous n'avez pas l'intention de partir
vous c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup samia ghali d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
non ça je sais merci à toutes et à tous
d'avoir suivi cette émission merci
beaucoup à ceux qui l'ont suivi en
direct sur twitter merci pour vos
questions dans le tchat merci à celles
et à ceux qui l'ont écoutée en podcast
et merci à toutes celles et à tous ceux
qui l'ont regardé en replay sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt
je vous dirais semaine prochaine pour le
retour de questions aux sénateurs à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]